dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fail you are going to
love this killer paper in the classical
case of 3d fabrication we first create
the 3d geometry in our modeling software
on a computer then after we are done we
send this model to a 3d printer to
create a physical copy of it if we don't
like an aspect of this printed model we
have to go back to the computer and
adjust accordingly if there are more
fundamental issues we may even have to
start over and get this with this piece
of work we can have a low fidelity
wireframe version printed immediately as
we make changes within the modeling
software this process we can refer to as
real-time or on-the-fly 3d printing in
this work both the hardware design and
the algorithm that runs the printer is
described this approach has a number of
benefits and of course a huge set of
challenges for instance we can
immediately see the result of our
decisions and can test whether a new
piece of equipment would correctly fit
into the scene we are designing
sometimes depending on the geometry of
the final object different jobs need to
be reordered to get a plan that is
physically plausible to print in this
example the bottom branch was designed
by the artist first and the top branch
afterwards but their order has to be
changed otherwise the bottom branch
would block the way to the top branch
the algorithm recognizes these cases and
reorders the printing jobs correctly
quite remarkable and an alternative
solution for rotating the object around
for better reach ability is also
demonstrated because of the fact that
the algorithm is capable of this sort of
decision-making we don't even need to
wait for the printer to finish a given
step and can remain focused on the
modeling process also the handle of the
teapot here collides with the body
because of the limitations of wireframe
modeling such cases have to be detected
and omitted
connecting patches and adding
differently sized holes to a model are
also highly non-trivial problems that
are all addressed in the paper and this
piece of work is also a testament to the
potential of solutions where hardware
and software is designed with each other
in mind I can only imagine how many work
hours were put in this project until the
final working solution was obtained
incredible work indeed we really just
scratch the surface in this episode make
sure to go to the video description and
have a look at the paper for more
details it's definitely worth it also if
you enjoyed these two minute papers
episode make sure to subscribe to the
series and if you're subscribed click
the bell icon to never miss an episode
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]